et on regardait ce que j'ai là bonjour à
tous je suis super content parce
qu'aujourd'hui on va tester un produit
que je vous ai déjà présentée lorsque
j'étais au cs à las vegas que j'ai
aujourd'hui chez moi grâce à mon
partenaire ja pon point net
le nouveau samsung galaxy à 8 et on va
le regarder le tester maintenant
[Musique]
il est sorti il est là il est beau il
est tout chaud le nouveau samsung galaxy
à 8 c'est le nouveau smartphone milieu
de gamme de samsung pour cette année il
succède au à 5 de 2017 et aux cinq qui
étaient déjà sortis quelques bonnes
années avant alors je les ai déjà pris
en main j'ai déjà testé ce produit je
trouve cool je trouve bien samsung
fabrique de très beaux écrans les
appareils photos sont de bonne qualité
mais j'ai testé un petit peu trop
succinctement j'étais présent sur un
stand aux crs
en plus je les fais au moment où il ya
une coupure de courant black out
ils ont fermé le cs pendant quelques
heures dans bon j'ai pu prendre en main
mais très rapidement trop rapidement
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
regarder ce à 8 voir ce qu'il a dans le
ventre
est ce qu'il est intéressant ce qu'ils
écoulent oui ou non et d'ailleurs je
vous invite à vous abonner parce que
c'est à 8 on va en parler beaucoup plus
que maintenant je vous fais tout de
suite une vidéo donne boxing une prise
en main au regard d'un petit peu les
grandes fonctionnalités comment ça se
passe je vous faire aussi très
rapidement une vidéo de test photo vidéo
complète parce quelques jours à la neige
en famille non vous en profitez pour
filmer plein de choses à partager tout
ça mais ça sera surtout l'occasion de
tester complètement ce galaxy à 8 parce
que je vais tout filmé avec je vous fais
aussi une troisième vidéo et
impressionne c'est un passe partout
quand je fais ça trois clés je vous
ferai une troisième vidéo dans laquelle
je vous donnerai plein d'astuces plein
d'infos sur les différentes nouvelles
fonctionnalités de ce samsung galaxy à 8
on commence tout de suite le voilà
samsung galaxy réduite donc on va
regarder un petit peu ce que ceux à huit
a dans le ventre
comment il est fait on va l'ouvrir
gradisca dans la boîte et puis on va
faire un tour complet puis à la fin je
vous dirai ce que j'en pense
alors la boîte déjà d'un point de vue
extérieur alors effectivement chez
autocollants de nos partenaires il a
faim de points n'est d'ailleurs merci
parce que c'est grâce à lui de voir tous
ces produits on regarde un petit peu bon
comme d'hab c'est une boîte qui est
plutôt sympa c'est très élégant alors
c'est assez minimaliste on retrouve les
infos principales galaxie à 8 32 gigas
l'écran bon on va râler tout ça tout à
l'heure les spécifications techniques
ici les numéros de série c'est le modèle
noir voilà donc on va l'ouvrir à un 1 1
on souffre comme ça par le bas pas mal
joli galaxie à 8 2018 merci d'avoir
précisé
j'ai cru que c'était le modèle de 2015
impunité display dual front de caméras
walter dust résistante résistant à l'eau
et à la poussière c'est la certification
ip68 alors hop je leur ai d'abord
regarder ce qu un petit peu dans la
boîte
toujours curieux de savoir comment ça se
passe alors qu'est-ce qu'on a paris si
quick start guide bien évidemment alors
qu'est-ce qu'il ya maintenant ici je
vois que j'ai à des écouteurs qui me
servent également de kit mains libres
pas mal cool
geci un câble usb avec de l'usb tisser
parce que oui chers amis le samsung
galaxy à 8 fonctionne avec de l'usb tilt
c'est comme les autres modèles
d'ailleurs entier
si vous ne saviez pas vous avez votre
chargeur
vous avez un adaptateur voilà vous avez
pas mal de petits trucs on à la base
l'essentiel maintenant on va regarder ce
qui se passe comment il est fichu alors
ici vous avez effectivement hop une
petite protection qu'on va enlever au
dos pareil une protection qu'on enlève
le voilà tout nu beau magnifique j'ai
l'impression qu'il est plus lourd moi
c'est plus qu'une impression il est plus
lourd que mon iphone si c'est ce côté
design sinon moi je trouve pas mal je
trouve que de toute façon samsung fait
vraiment de beaux produits vous avez la
présence à l'avant ici de la double
caméra frontale vous avez ici vos
capteurs votre haut parleurs alors c'est
un écran 5,6 pousse ici le bouton de
volume la place pour votre carte sim qui
est juste ici connectique usb tissé par
jack bravo de l'avoir gardé le bouton
pour allumer à l'arrière la caméra qui
se situe ici le capteur d'empreintes
digitales là le flash
alors moi je voulais souvent dit je suis
pas très fan de l'emplacement je pense
que lorsque vous posez votre doigt vous
avez toujours tendance à laisser un bout
du doigt directement sur le la caméra
pour le chercher et ça laisse des traces
et sauf que c'est pas vraiment optimales
il avait mis ici sur la suite c'était
pas mieux
je pense que sa place comme je vous ai
déjà dit à se situer à peu près ici
d'ailleurs ça paraît plus logique plus
naturel noyés lorsque je le prends
d'avoir la prof point que
allez je vais arrêter de chipoter enfin
je trouve que dans l'ensemble c'est un
produit qui est plutôt sympa assez
élégant je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez et en plus il a une particularité
c'est d'avoir la double carte sim
vous avez ici votre lecteur de carte sim
principal est là qui s'appelle sim
1 vous avez donc ensuite ici sur le
dessus la deuxième partie qui est là où
vous avez votre carte sim numéro 2 qui
va se loger ici et votre carte mémoire
qui va se loger là alors vous me direz
l'intérêt d'avoir deux cartes sim c'est
quoi pour moi l'intérêt d'avoir deux
cartes sim
c'est vraiment dédié soit aux
professionnels qui ont effectivement des
besoins dans ce sens qu'ils qui ont un
numéro perso et un numéro pro soit
lorsque vous partez à l'étranger ça vous
évite ça vous permet de prendre une
carte sim étrangères pour ne pas
défoncer votre forfait dans la mesure
n'avait pas de surf international
alors maintenant on va l'allumer pour
voir un petit peu ce que ça dit samsung
galaxy à 8 android
salut toi comment es tu oi oi oi oi
paramétrage de la configuration la
reconnaissance faciale
préparez-vous à déverrouiller votre
téléphone à l'aide de votre visage
tenez votre téléphone est distant de 20
50 cm de votre visage positionnez votre
visage dans le cercle affiche à l'écran
votre visage a été enregistrée
recruteurs c'est hyper rapide là je suis
vraiment curieux de voir si ça marche
bien la reconnaissance faciale me mets
devant instantané c'est incroyable je
l'éteins je me cache un faux pas qui me
reconnaissent là ces écrans dérouiller
c'est hyper rapide c'est cool pour vous
en parler un peu plus en détails il faut
savoir qu'on a un écran panoramique ce
qu'ils appellent panoramique 5,6 pouces
super amoled 2220 pixels par 1080 une
résolution de 441 ppp
l'appareil photo vous avez un double
appareil photo à l'avant vous avez un 16
mégapixels un 8 mégapixels tous les deux
ont une ouverture de f
1.9 à l'arrière vous avez une caméra ici
de 16 mégapixels avec une ouverture f
1.7
vous avez aussi votre flash vous avez
pas notre choix j'avais le mode portrait
et de collants vous allez les filtres il
tourne sous un android 7 points un point
nous gardent une surcouche expérience y
8.5 le processeur c'est un processeur
samsung en exil aux 7885 à huit coeurs
cadencés à 2 2
gigahertz la puce graphique c'est une
arm mal dit j'ai 71
il a 4 gigas de ram 32 gigas de stockage
que vous pouvez monter grâce à votre
extension ici à 256 giga il faut savoir
sur les 32 vous avez 22,7 géant du
stockage qui sont disponibles il a une
certification ip68 à l'eau et à la
poussière je peux mettre de l'eau dessus
cinq craint pas du bluetooth 5.0 une
batterie 3000 milliampères heures hélas
une fonction qui est cool c'est la
fonction double application c'est à dire
que vous pouvez par exemple utiliser
deux réseaux sociaux en même temps si
vous avez par exemple de consommables
chatte vous pouvez dupliquer
l'application dès lors que l'application
vous l'autorisez d'ailleurs vous invite
aussi à vous abonner parce que toutes
ses astuces faciles voulu donner très
rapidement dans une future vidéo
côté dimensions effet 14,12 de hauteur
une profondeur de 7,06 et une épaisseur
de 0,84 et pour un poids de 172 g et
côté tarifs c'est un smartphone qui
coûtent moins de 500 euros à 499 euros
comme je vous le dis la caméra je vous
ferai un test un peu plus tard division
c koi s'activer bec division et dirigez
votre appareil photo sur un objet ou un
placement diana un produit intéressant
ça on testera aussi un peu plus tard
j'ai d'un côté ici les différents modes
auto pro panorama par l'aps nuit à
l'image peut en télécharger d'autres
j'ai sur le côté ici plein de filtres
différents crème profond forêt classique
j'ai ici mais autocollants qui peuvent
être assez marrant pour les superposer
alors effectivement fallait que je mette
ma tronche en face ça fait quand je
regarde comme ça ça a l'air d'être
plutôt qualitatif vous le dis on fera un
test un peu plus poussé ultérieurement
la caméra la double caméra à l'avant
mise au point en direct alors là on voit
garder up salut ça c'est moi on peut
effectivement lycée davantage
on peut régler la cool
assez cool ça celle-ci vous le mettez en
très grand écran pour pouvoir se voir ça
c'est pas mal ça la reconnaissance du
visage marche pas trop mal
ici tous les réglages de l'appareil
photo taille de l'image taille de la
vidéo on a dû fhd si vous voulez filmé
en 4k il vous faudra aller sur un galaxy
et suite voir sur le galaxy s 9 au final
ce galaxy à 8
je trouve bien je trouve plutôt pas mal
sur la prise en main je trouve que au
niveau photo vidéo de ce que j'ai en moi
pour l'instant derrière génial comme je
vous le dis on va regarder un peu plus
tard plus en profondeur ce qu'il en est
côté applications c'est pareil et je
vous ferai une autre vidéo on va vous
créant fougue et l'ol sont vraiment
rares d'escattes dans pour une première
prise en main voilà je suis plutôt
satisfait je suis plutôt très
enthousiaste vous dites moi ce que vous
en pensez est ce que vous pensez que ce
nouveau samsung galaxy à 8 est un
excellent produit à moins de 500 euros
et ça il faut pas l'oublier ça fait
quand même un peu la différence
dites moi tout ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous trouvez
qu'il écoulait ce que vous trouvez qu'il
est pas cool merci en tout cas d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo je vous invite comme
je vous le dis à vous abonner parce que
on va reparler très très très vite dans
les jours qui viennent
et puis on va les rencontrer son grand
frère qui va arriver d'ici quelques
jours au mwc à barcelone
donc restez connectés mettez-moi tous
vos commentaires vous invite comme nadal
mais ces deux jolies pouces restez
connectés je vous embrasse
soyez sages et à très bientôt ciao
[Musique]